quelle tâche de gauche votre nom que cet
abominable affaire dreyfus voilà l'une
des citations du célèbre j'accuse
d'emile zola un texte adressé au
président de la république félix faure à
travers la presse le jeudi 13 janvier
1898 l'un des basculements de l' affaire
dreyfus raconté ici dans ce musée à
médan à travers différents objets
historiques du côté de refuser on est
plus sur la pérennité long terme et on
va utiliser le livre la brochure
essentiellement alors que du côté anti
dreyfusards on n'est plus dans
l'immédiateté l'idée c'est de convaincre
le plus rapidement possible être
convaincre la rue donc on va avoir comme
ça a énormément de le flyer existe déjà
en fait il est différent il est rond il
est petit on le met en pilon c'est un
mal qu'on lançait il vole des flyers
pour rappel alfred dreyfus et un
officier français de confession juive il
a été victime d'une machination
antisémite organisé par l'état cette
affaire résonne avec la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme et le racisme des sujets
abordés à travers la visite du musée
dreyfus penser avec un volet pédagogique
destiné aux élèves des collèges et
lycées dans le musée on a à travers tout
ce qui est montré les documents la
possibilité de s'appuyer de s'adosser à
la réalité d'une histoire de notre pays
et puis il y aura la possibilité au sous
sol à partir de tutoriels à partir de
films à partir de vidéos de retravailler
tous ces thèmes juste à côté du musée
dreyfus la maison d'emile zola elle est
ouverte au public de 1985 jusqu'en 2011
fermez la bâtisse et restaurer le musée
dreyfus est conçu une restauration
fidèles à l'époque d'emile zola comme
son cabinet le bureau où il a écrit ses
plus grandes oeuvres là vous êtes mandat
lieu de créativité littéraire un refuge
c'est à tour d'ivoire donc cela arrivait
ici au mois de mai jusqu'au mois de
décembre il écrivait l'équivalent de
quatre pages manuscrites par jour ce
n'est pas beaucoup mais cela ne suffit
pas de décrire il dit toujours que il
veut bâtir son oeuvre comme une
symphonie musicale la bête humaine
l'assommoir ou germinal les lignes de
ses oeuvres résonne encore dans ses murs
au bonheur des visiteurs qui pourront
découvrir ce site aux destins liés à
partir du 28 octobre 2021